the uh the agent who is finding me my
apartment
yeah i watched her youtube i didn't tell
her my youtube right but they had to
know my company yeah
of course and so i think she just went
on the company so i saw my name she
watched my youtube video i was like oh
god
well you just got are you youtubers yeah
i was like oh cool
which one did you watch and she was like
i watched you drinking alcohol and i was
like
with chris and i'm like oh my god
what a terrible introduction to me like
here's what i do for a job i get
squashed
film indoors you know honestly i'm
barely talking frankly that's how i got
my place yeah i literally had to like
tell the people who i was applying it to
they were like you can't tell anything
yeah
so because they like the person who owns
my place
like watch my youtube because like they
had to know as well because i was
applying under my company so they're all
like
so are all your videos filmed inside i'm
just like no no most of these are
outside and they're like okay
to be fair i never record past like five
six p.m
anyway it's just streams which again i
mean i remember
you said before in london you used to
record like two a.m or three years my
neighbors didn't give a [ __ ] though but
then again they were blasting peppa pig
through the wall like 2 a.m so i don't
really
what kid is watching everything like mom
put on the episode but
this one's a banger turn it up mum set
it up i don't know if it's
my favorite op i don't know if it's
because i was in like a kind of
like uh not great area of london i don't
know if there's a mutual understanding
where like no complaints no no police
no police because my neighbors had like
10 people living in a house
that had like two bedrooms right so i
don't know how
how much police they wanted over there
yeah like that's why i'm pretty sure
they never ever said anything because
one time
uh multiple times actually i opened the
door to get a package from them
and it looked like you know like uh just
like
so many [ __ ] people were living in
there it was crazy i was like
it was very weird so i think that's why
they never complained yeah and also the
walls are thicker